[Applaudissements]
elle avait de tout petits bons
valentinee Valentine
elle avait de tout petites t que je
tatais à taton Tonon tonelle elle avait
un tout petit menton
Valentine
Valentine outre ses petits petit peon
elle était frisée comme un
mouton on se rappelle toujours sa
première amie j'ai gardé de la mienne un
souvenir pour la vie un jour qu'il avait
plus tous deux on sétait plus et puis on
se PL de plus en plus je lui demandé son
nom elle me dit
Valentine et comme elle prenait chaque
jour la rue Custine je pris le même
chemin et puis je lui pris la main je
l'embrassais enfin
elle avait de tout petit peton
Valentine Valentine
[Musique]
elle av fait de doues petit péton que je
Tavais àaton tant qu' contraire
elleavait un tout petit mon
valentinee
Valentine ses petites Éton ces
petit étons et je ne m'en rappelle plus
du
tout